- En colère, solidaires!
En colères, solidaires!
Wade a eu l'effet d'une bougie
ge. Elles ont envahi
le parvis du Palais de justice
les Américaines. Ces militantes
de longucroyaient pas
devoir reprendre le flambeau.-Çe
décourage. Je suis complètement
consternée, dévastée et en
colère.SSÉ, Québec Solidaire,
- Ce que je veux dire à ces
dictateurs de nos corps, là,
c'est que nos corps, en 2022,
et ils n'ont pas à faire ni des
lois, ni des anti-lois qui
viennent agir sur nos corps.
- On est les descendantese vousz
pas pu brûler.
- Les femmes craignent que
le vent conservateur du sud
canadien.
pas vrai que tout est
acquis ici. Il faut continuer
d'être éveillés pcontre
l'avortement, eux, ils ne
pas. Eux, ils pensent
à nous tout le temps.
- L'érosion des droits
le monde, rappelle cet homme.
JULIEN DAIGNEAULT, Alternati
socialiste
- C'est pas juste une attaque
aux droique au droit de tout
le monde de fonder la famille
quand ils veulent, où ils le
veulent et ils et elles veulent.
- Les voix des féministes ses
de la province : à Rimouski,
SherbrooRivières.
À Québec, cette mère a dû
se faire avorter, un sujet
- Dans ma famille, il y a eu
plusieurs avortements dans
les générations passées.
J'ai des proches qui ont dû
avorter. Moi-même
avorter... parce qu'on peut
nceinte avec
contraception. Il y en a
- Une femme sur trois aura à
avortement dans sa vie,
selon la Fédération du Quebec
des planning des naissances.
soit mieux protégé au Canada,
son accégale.
MARIE-CLAUDE BIBEAU, député,
Parti libéral du Canada,
de le rendre plus accessible
à travers le pays.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a
dans ce sens-là. Donc au Canada
jeu c'est plutôt
d'augmenter l'accès.
pour des millions d'Américaines.
Un mépris envers toutes les
femmes, disent les féministes,
qui n'au
que de reprendre le combat.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montréal.